okay  I'm not gonna lie I think Germany's kind  of a country doesn't mean I think  Germans are lesser than Americans I just  don't like your policies  well that is racist because you would  say that like Germans are shitty no I  think Germany is a crappy country  why is  you don't have freedom of speech is one  of them  popular speak to jail people for  offensive speech yes you do no I don't  know okay I'm not going to argue with  you it is 100 accurate  you do not have freedom of speech and  Shrine in the German Constitution it  doesn't exist no yes they're arrested  they're arrested if they use hateful  skills because of course yeah  Nazis you guys started it